foreign
[Music]
I'm a senior lecturer in central
technology at Cranford University in the
UK today I will talk about crispr's
enabled paper microphobic device for
Rapid diagnostics for people who don't
know Cranford University which is
exclusively postgraduate student to
University
based in the north of London which is
around one hour away from London
Cambridge and Oxford so it's quite easy
to access
so as you know there's a lot of
challenges for pathogen detection
either for biomedical diagnosed gnostics
or environmental and Public Health
or food safety and this is a very
important detection
techniques for those pathogens
conventional detection method relies on
culture method which is time consuming
takes days or weeks and less thanatives
there is a
very very popular method which is
molecular method especially over the
past several years of pandemic
everywhere now knows a PCR method for
testing out sasko to viral genetic
material however this technology is very
much relies on the central Laboratories
and the real trainer skilled persons to
carry out the sample processing analyze
and the data Integrations
so it's not a
always use a useful or popular in a
resource limiting areas
so there's to a
to address these challenges on the
pathogen detections there is a great
need for Rapid low cost sensitive and a
portable sensing platform enabled to
drop a test in this passages or for all
these applications
so I will give you some our recent work
on this on our development
or on the paper-based my paper-based
device or paper microphilic device for
Rapid diagnosis
coupled with molecular methods such as
isothermal amplification and crispr
casts enabled molecular sa to improve
the sensitivity and specificity finally
I will give you some more recent work on
the west order surveillance as a new
public health tool to address the
infection disease disease challenges
when we talk about the papermography
device
we we always want to mention a
science hero Professor JoJo Weinstein
from Harvard
uh
University who is Pioneer who has
pioneered paper microphone device
more than a decade ago
so he firstly proposed paper as a
substrate to fabricate electrons and a
make a new glucose meter for monitoring
diabetes there is a lot of applications
emerging in both as paper microphobic
electrodes or
pepper as a
simple preparation steps
sample preparation steps for the
different sensing application
in our
approach we're using to develop a
uniquely affording and unfolding paper
device which is wax printed to formulate
hydrophobic and hydrophobic layer which
can used as can be used as a sample
preparation steps so as you can see from
here it's a mainly composed of three
parts one is a paper-based device so we
have the black layer which is a wax can
be have a
hydrophobic and this white layers area
is uh
hydraulic hydraulic so let's say we can
use as a fluidic channel to process
these samples
and we also have a glass fiber which can
physically absorb and absorb nucleic
acid
because of interaction of electrostatic
interaction
and we also have a plastic plate which
can accommodate the isothermal
amplification in order to improve the
signals so what we do is in our platform
we will first introduce samples into
class fiber after licenses of these
clinical samples which might be from
blood
saliva or semen samples like this glass
fiber can electrostatically
absorb this nuclear acid
then we can go through the washing using
washing buffer to purify those DNA
material or any material but they wash
off the numbness
radius so afterwards we can elude this
genetic material from glass fiber and
go through this file spots or five star
microfilic channel into this plastic
plate then we introduce the reagents to
make the isothermaline application have
amplification happens so basically we
can use either Loop mediator or The Loop
mediated ISO multiplication or a
Cooperative with crisp cards enabler
amplification so the whole is a takes
less than one hour that's pretty much
fast and enabled sample to answer
analysis
so we have initially developed this
method for the veterinary diagnosis and
maybe you are still have some confusion
on this workflow I have a very short
video to let you go through this process
okay uh this is a
emergence
what we captured within the field
testing of paper-based device in a local
Indian farm so basically we tested a
small cohort of semen sample for the
veteran infection disease diagnosis so
we can either read the results using
like the eyes from the calorimetrical
change or capture the image to do the
same quantification with these three
pathogens
let's use a sexual transmitted infection
disease or provide
so this testing if you're testing just
give us confidence to use as a testing
case in the field
we further implement this technology
by changing the design of this paper
micro vertical platform and also
improved the detection method from the
calorimetric detection
to lateral flow device and sometimes
there is a background light can have
tiny influence on your results so we
firstly developed this method and test a
small cohort of sample in our lab and
together with
collaborators we travel to local
Primary School in Uganda in Africa we're
testing malaria samples from local
school students now compare these
results with the gold standard rpq PCR
method as you can see we have a very
competitive sensitivity and specificity
we feel this is another example we
choose this paper-based platform
coupled with rt lamp which is because we
are targeting hepatitis
hepatitis C virus
hcv we're using a ultimate process to do
the isothermal amplification and also
we're using this lateral fluid device to
test the positive negative results we
can also test the wire load by this
optimization of the detection results
this is we developed this method and
also validate this in the lab-based
samples then we go for the as a cohort
of clinical samples showing a very
promising testing results which is
validated by rtq PCR method
here is another example we we best we in
collaboration within a group from
University of Edinburgh we publish
results and continue to further improve
the molecular essay together with the
class 9 platform because it is a Agatha
sensors so we basically
find a new design a new mechanism which
is only dependent within the UN
RNA we can also trigger this cleavage
translation
cleavage cleavage and then using this
class 9 as a cast cast online to improve
the sensor we prove this concept and and
using a
mobile camera to capture the image for
carometric detection so this is uh just
to show us we can flexibly detect the
ion sensor for different viral
pathogen detection
to give a brief sum up based on these
origami paper sensor it has a lot of
advantages such as it's very cheap which
less than one pounds including reagents
and a device
as well as rapid which can provide a
sample to answer detection within an
hour
the device the surf is very user
friendly as you can see here the picture
which I took
during the trip my Indian trip after
training the
local student within a half now within
several hours they can run this device
independently so this is extremely
useful to test the pathogens in a field
for um point of use or point of need
analysis
so we have approved and demonstrated a
few applications using origami paper
device for pathogen detections however
if the pandemic almost allows a lot of
new technology for this rapid diagnosis
of infection disease especially coupled
with Chris Focus technology here I want
to introduce you some new Concepts as a
public health tools as
last year Science magazine has
summarized
125 ground questions for the exploration
and the discoveries one of the frontal
medicine and health sections can we
predict the next pandemic
as the international travel climate
change this potential epidemic may come
up again or especially for some new
violence if we can make as much more
ready much ready for the future pandemic
that if we are
save us a lot of economic laws and and
money at people's life
so potentially Wastewater surveillance
could be as a potential tool for this
Public Health Management
firstly
let's explain you what is a Wastewater
surveillance
so the concept is that each people will
shared viral particle or pathogens into
the toilet if we get a
virus or infections so this virus will
travel into the toilet end up in the
westward children plans if we call
example to analyze those viral particles
so this will probably extremely early
information that in the before that even
to before the symptom developed here is
a Time window should even people have
might or no symptoms they still share
this viral particle into the Wastewater
basically we can monitor them and give
us a holy warning uh information for
this transmission of infection disease
typically it can be five to seven days
earlier
so that's why this is so important to uh
monitoring waste water
okay so here this map tells you
what happening in the world
since the first report of the south
coventory in West water in March 2020
from Westward children plan around the
skiffle airport in the Netherlands
currently there were more than 24
countries who is carrying out Regional
National Monitoring program and to
support the data from the CTC of Public
Health reagents from the government so
firstly this testing
was carried out in the western plan but
now it has fully expanded to different
scenario such as care homes for
neosource tracking Hospital School hotel
or universities the world was successful
example in 2020 Arizona State University
has managed to test the stats coverage
in West water and then give an early
warning for the students to to move out
and minimize this infection
however in the analytical process how
can we detest those Wastewater symbol
for a how can we test the subscribing
Westward samples so this is a typical
workflow as you can see that you need to
collect samples from Westward treatment
plan and then do the process control and
during the sample processing then you
draw extraction this nucleic acid from
Wastewater so the PCR as you're testing
in clinical samples so that's a quite
long process which may takes over 24
hours with the 10 Rounds
the question is can we really test
testing Wastewater on the side of the
summer collection in order to provide
this immediate and valuable information
to the local government agent in order
to build up this early Warning Systems
so here paper microphotic device might
be a solution so that would be more
sensitive faster at a ble to carry out
the testing in the field
however there is a big difference
between the Wastewater samples and the
clinical samples one big difference is
the sample size of Wastewater usually
needs milliliter scales typically it's
50 50 milliliter however
clinical sample only needs micro liter
levels so and also those such coated
particles has extremely low
concentration in Wastewater thus needs
as a sample processing steps so several
years ago we have developed this uh very
best keys for the extraction of nuclei
acid from waste water so so basically
we're using a single filtration systems
to enrich those pathogens using magnetic
beads to extract and purify this
nucleiastical material carry and then
carry out a lump at isosome
amplification to test this genetic
material then we can using a lateral
fluid device to read out these results
so this is the data we carried out as a
proof of concept study in a local
wastewater treatment plants
based on this sample per enrichment
method for Wastewater and using our
paper-based platform together with uh
cast 12 a
systems we managed to test this such
color
too in Wastewater samples so we're using
either parametrical diet as a readout or
using electrical fluid to test the two
samples to show the feasibility of a
point of need analysis
so the whole method the whole mechanism
is that in the presence of such country
quantity quantities of applicants are
generated via RT lump which could
actively the trans cleavage of the cast
12 a uh Guardian RNA complex then the
complex asset specific or specifically
and the rarely Clips the single strand
improves the first fluorescence is
generated due to the separation of the
fluorescence and the quench in the
fluorescence method so however in a
lateral flute method we can also there
is a strong test strand band is produced
due to the separation of the diet and
about biotin because the former could
combine within a modified
modified modified gmps and it becomes
immobilized on the test lines while the
latter is fixed on the control line so
based on this one we can either using
the visual data
for the detection or using the lateral
fluid device for the rapid testing
device for especially useful for the
diagnosis diagnosis purpose
here is the results choose our
sensitivity this is crispr cards enable
the molecular asset together with
peppermography device for testing of
different concentration of such country
in Wastewater
so as you can see that we can either
using the Frozen dye or using lateral
fluid device to test this signals
and then we can normalize to allow semic
quantitative detection results
based on this proof of concept of study
we uh we also carry out the field
testing in the
quantity Hotel over the summer
in in the UK in LA in the UK so we
basically test a week and carry a
carry out the sum a sample from five
sides of Colony Hotel from Monday to
Friday so we test the three Targets on
the search cover to Gene sequence and
then we just use the different
sensitivity depending on the samples and
we found that
um
within the combination of this sequence
it can improve the sensitivity for this
Wastewater surveillance and also
typically energy has more sensitivity
than S genes that's because it's more
stable in the west water
and then finally
we
to give a quick sum up we have already
issue this paper origami device as a
sensing platform for the diagnosis and a
Wastewater testing for public health so
we basically and detect develop a few
protocols for different sample detection
including clinical samples such as semen
blood water Wastewater and we also show
the feasibility for different pathogen
detection from South cover to influencer
E coli E coli or salmonella for the
water contaminant contamination or
Veterinary diagnosis as well as a human
infection disease such as malaria or the
TB so the whole testing platform is
let's say 45 minutes and it's very cheap
let's say one pounds but it provides
special specific detection within a
point of care application it can also
highly multiplexed for different
pathogen detections however to address
the pandemic challenges we need to
combine with different Technologies such
as big data or machine learning
techniques to real-time monitoring use
prevalence of infection disease within
the population from the neighborhood
levels to the population levels
finally I just want to show you this is
kind of our contribution on this
Wastewater surveillance work we quickly
partner within ucap academic to
contribute to the National Wastewater
surveillance program and also to attract
a lot of attentions we published well
the first paper of this paper-based
device for SAS coffee detection in
Wastewater and dating back to March 2020
and it's all also featured in The
Science magazine after the first testing
polishing samples from the Wastewater in
Paris so now this paper device has been
displayed in London Science Museum if
you are interested you are very welcome
to have a look
finally I just end up with my talk
within a small video
from the BBC interview
now a way of spotting covid outbreaks
much more quickly is being developed by
scientists at Cranfield University in
bedfordshire and the answer lies in
well something none of us particularly
want to think about human waste our
science correspondent Richard Wescott
reports
the key to controlling covert outbreaks
is to spot the virus as soon as possible
and this is where you'll find clues that
it's spreading at the local sewage works
now it's not the most Pleasant thought
but one way that the body gets rid of
the coronavirus is through feces and
that means that by testing sewage you
can track down outbreaks in towns and
Villages and that is where this clever
simple little device comes in
scientists at Cranfield University are
developing a paper test to find covid in
our waste using chemicals and filters it
can spot genetic material left behind by
the virus but it's inactive so they say
you won't catch covered from the water
it's designed to be cheap easy for
anyone to use and gives a result in an
hour green light means there's covert
around it can be widely used as a
routine test for example the schools and
Care Homes or even
hospitals or even hotels Leisure Center
like some public places to monitoring
this waste water up the road they're
testing at the University's own sewage
Works they say the technique could find
hot spots much sooner than current swab
tests
okay finally I would like thanks
very much for my Founders collaborators
and my students who contribute a lot of
this work thanks so much for your
attention